le défilé départemental du 14 juillet
2015 qui s'est déroulée au barachois à
saint denis a été marquée cette année
par la présence d'une soixantaine de
jeunes réunionnais parmi les troupes du
sdiss 36 jeunes sapeurs pompiers des
sections ouest et nord est en activité
sur l'île et 24 élèves en première année
de baccalauréat professionnel sécurité
et prévention du lycée patu de rosemont
ont défilé pour la première fois sa
présente janvier car c'est pas tout le
monde qui a la chance de deux défilés au
14 juillet les anciens bas qu il avait
pas eu la chance de dire sur place nous
on a eu la chance de pouvoir défiler
donc en eux ça fait ça fait un choc en
fait mais pour moi ça représentait un
grand honneur parce que on a eu une
autre section a eu la chance cette année
de 10 filets alors que les anciens bacs
pros on n'a pas eu cette chance et c'est
beaucoup d'émotion donc c'est très bien
ça représente pour nous une fierté
à l'honneur beaucoup de joie et si on
trouve un peu de stress vu que c'est la
première fois qu'on défile une grande
joie pour les familles qui n'auraient
raté ce moment pour rien au monde voir
leurs enfants défilé pour la fête
nationale représente une vraie fierté
pour ses parents donc bien pour nous
c'est la première fois qu'on vient voir
défiler sur saint denis et si tu te
d'honneur de voir un autre fruit des
filières ce matin et de voir qu'il ya
des jeunes qui ça qui se donne aussi aux
os curité quoi civile c'est ma fierté
c'est ma fierté c'est un désert que
j'avais moi aussi ben voilà aujourd'hui
elle accomplit un petit peu mon rêve
mais c'est une fiat et c'est un honneur
ben elle déjà elle vit son rêve son
premier rêve elle a toujours voulu faire
de la gendarmerie donc grâce à des bus
de son bref c'est un commencement et on
est fiers d'eux on est content pour elle
en fait au total près de cent six
sapeurs-pompiers se sont réunis au
barachois pour ce rendez vous annuel
malgré leur expérience l'honneur et la
joie reste intacte pour les pompiers qui
défilent avant tout avant tout c'est une
fierté
c'est une fierté et puis le fait de
représenter ou également le service des
trois essais et de mettre en avant le
secours médical et la fonction
d'affaires bien sapeurs pompiers au
quotidien à défiler au 14 juillet c'est
une jeune fille qui était de représenter
notre belle institution qui est le 19
sept quatre et c'est le moment où 6 2
de montrer les
nos véhicules
l'étudiante spécialité présenter notre
métier ou
les gars la population c'est une fierté
pour moi et donc depuis quinzaine
d'années je défie pratiquement tous les
ans et cette année sont codifiés t pour
moi et j'espère encore d'ici l'année
prochaine et les années suivantes
et donc pour moi c'est jean-pierre bon
pour moi c'est les uniformes cette
vielle pompiers donc on me dit la devise
sauver se courir pour le préfet
dominique sorain ce 14 juillet est l'un
des plus beaux qu'ils aient vu arriver
il ya moins d'un an à la réunion ce
défilé présente une symbolique
particulière assis ce moment c'est le
premier 14 juillet que j'ai passées ici
à la réunion est conforme à ce qu'on
m'avait dit c'est une très très belle
fête populaire le 14 juillet c'est
d'abord une fête populaire qui marque
air france et des filets guetteront des
participants qui met en une heure les
militaires des forces de sécurité les
associations aussi en matière de
sécurité civile réduire c'était un des
plus beaux 14 juillet vous pour ce 14
juillet 2015 le 6 9 7 4 a souhaité
mettre en avant la thématique de
l'intégration par la formation de la
jeunesse réunionnaise